again I'm not a predator even though a
lot of you think so because five years
ago I made a bark joke
what horrible five years ago you made a
fart joke so insanely disrespectful how
are you gonna actually reduce it to that
that's the Becky story oh she's calling
it girl what is wrong with you yeah wow
are you serious you brought a young girl
on stage you exploited her body and you
called it a fart joke she didn't
complain about the farm joke I don't
think that's what bothered her yeah yeah
I'm pretty sure that's not what bothered
her did that's so up I'm laughing
because it's so up it's nasty
this girl actually came out and talked
about it as like a grown-up and you're
like man it's just a fart joke grow up
holy that's super unhinged